the city of a go-go in the center of
Ghana John and malossi and his research
team are making their third visit to the
home of Teresa Sarpong and her family
the reason her daughter Michelle had
acute diarrhea a few weeks ago I said
well I was really afraid for her she was
so weak and small children can die from
diarrhea grand from woo in Kenya name is
true Michelle had caught a highly
infectious parasitic disease known as
cryptosporidiosis John Emma wazee has
been researching it with his team for
some time now and they want to find out
exactly how it is transmitted that's why
they've been visiting the patients in
their homes they get worried because
they think that well they must have a
very strange and very serious diseases
is why people have come all the way from
town in white coats and wearing gloves
to take their blood or talk them
questions and then the risk of that is
apart from they being worried and
anxious then people can stigmatize them
so this is the guy who brought the
people from town well there's a guy for
which the people came all the way from
town to take his blood and act all
questions he must have serious issues
maybe we need to avoid him the diagnosis
of cryptosporidiosis was confirmed at
the local hospital it is regarded as a
neglected tropical disease and many
cases have been diagnosed maruli ulcer
patients are treated in another room
it's an infectious disease of the skin
how it is contracted is still unknown it
is another example of the so-called
neglected tropical diseases the patients
here are lucky that the hospital is
participating in a research project that
is why they are treated free of charge
the focus really is on our patients the
people who are neglected these are the
poorest of the poor who cannot afford
medicines that is if the medicines even
exists they cannot access them so it is
really the people who are neglected one
hour away and gone a second biggest city
kumasi john mo Ozzy heads the African
research Network for neglected tropical
diseases the network's goal is to
provide policy procedures to improve
treatment of rare diseases or even
better to completely eradicate them
muwah see also lobbies for funding for
the costly research to convince African
governments and the super-rich to become
more involved after all his samples
still must be sent to Europe because
they lack the necessary equipment at
home the very frustrating thing is when
you have the ability to do something and
you don't have the tools to be able to
do it it's a very frustrating thing I
know how that feels when you know you
can save a life when you know you can
make a difference but you just don't
have the tool to be able to execute the
work that you want to do and a lot of
people trained in Europe and North
America come back to several African
countries and they end up going back
because after a few months of work they
realize that look I'm not able to do
what I was trained to do I cannot offer
my best service here and they end up
going back John emwazi says heading back
to the US where he studied is completely
out of the question even though he is
now often flying around the world for
the network he enjoys his rare visits to
his country he wants to be able to help
people like Michelle and his vision is
clear a continent free of tropical
diseases yo is it